I woke up at 4:30 this morning woke up
at 4:45 because we are on a mission it's
really to find the best fast-food
hashbrown the patties potatoes are an
amazing thing
potatoes are almost as versatile as pigs
rubric Chris penis fluffiness
we brought a scale so we could weigh
them overall beauty
Wow pack without factor damn that's a
fine potato that's like that's a sexy 9
yes actually not oh here's the thing
when you break open a hash brown
it should steam like in the commercials
you know like you should break it in
half and steam cheer up keep testing
hang right here then take a left down by
will be in Santa Monica in the other
time we're here the Dunkin Donuts
looking for some hashbrowns we're gonna
get one or two hashbrowns and two
coffees that's gonna top down and see
how huge dunkin donut is beautiful 39
grams that's incredible team testing
test any high you're gonna say soft Mel
on this team test it's like a salty
tongue bath it can't give it too much
crispy or fluffy points cuz they kind of
blend together yep there's no contrast
contrast no wow factor
no factor it has something special about
it the thing is they're very eatable I
could I could just easy to get one order
and when maybe still got two well we
have to eat a lot more potatoes I didn't
want us to spoil our goose this early
yeah it is with potato fact Linda the
potato is about 80% water and twenty
percent solids 80% water
how's Junior all right senior watch
after that we're honor this is what
we're gonna get
ooh whoa we lost two lost 215 ten team
test you see any I didn't see any but it
felt better than the last time well
let's artisan what that much fluffed out
no it's just really a nice crunch
this is classic potato that's been fried
in a shape definitely no wow factor
ready yeah oh that was close though
waste another one oh that's my boy same
edibility
okay I'm through about ten on the ground
hashtag hashbrown hunt down 2k15
I hope we're gonna phone our mouths all
right we wasted a couple ash browns but
in the end it's really gonna be okay
because I mean the seagulls will you
everybody like seagulls at their
restaurant I'm gonna be honest I'm
already feeling a little bit sick Oh
Burger King where dreams can be yours
may I get an order of hash browns she's
nice I'll then pensive America's have
been nice today yeah this morning they
haven't had their day ruined yet I think
these liquation in like ireally they're
exactly the same 118 grams I might even
give a slight wow factor yeah I think
they're ugly capped ability favourable
even been passed down to 15 god damn it
this is not as easy as digging watch you
can copy any pants I got beyond my past
vibes were buds and nice times we were
eating this puzzle
potato blossoms used to be a big hit in
royal fashion potatoes first became
fashionable when Marie Antoinette
paraded through the French countryside
wearing potato blossoms in her hair
where are we Chris I'm at the
combination Pizza Hut and Taco Bell
that's where I am to and Linda okay okay
huh it looks hot average 39 grams it's
not crispy and it's not puffy Wow it's
like gooey yeah I don't like this no wow
that is the wow factor is like wow like
really it's probably the ugliest one
talk about I love you but you're new at
this breakfast thing and it's showing
catchable hashtag hashbrown hunt down
through K 15 flavor bud flavor buds
should be taste buds but thank you thank
you how mad do you get when somebody
doesn't give you the wave
you gotta give you gotta give them away
of give them away of give them away
thank you just wave at me hey did you
guys have hash browns
yeah nice man all right yeah how's it
going deep nice to meet you hey Chris
so now and since I'm going with us to
jack-in-the-box I've been throwing out
the jacket buck woo three fat Brown
alright 50 grams
oh what a seam - ooh it smells really
hot I liked about that the outsides a
nice room
and then when you feel the potato you're
out nice and smooth what do you think
well that's a fine potato Wow the first
one came out really nice now the other
two kind of failed on that department so
there was a clear better-looking sister
yes what a treat
yeah that's really great by the average
American eats about a hundred and twenty
four pounds of potatoes per year well
Germans eat about twice as much remember
that that's eighty percent water so
you're really just staying hydrated
we're finally going McDonald's so we
made it to our final destination
McDonald's and you know it's right next
door we have 20 minutes let's go get
some recruits right we're all gonna get
hashbrowns we're getting hash browns
that donald man named come on oh let's
go let's go learning at donald this cuz
this is important to her video come hash
browns we're all getting hash browns
every one of us and fifty let's get it
even 50 hi can I get 50 hash browns me
and Keith tweeted that we want to eat
hash browns and people okay it was like
I'll be there there it is
58 grams oh it's fine everything's for
fines perfect crunch perfect perfect
whap naturally beautiful yeah yeah every
time it gets so a factor damn that is a
fine potato what a special day we've had
as the taste buds but we're going to
sign off with our classic hashtag
hashbrown hunt down two days busy
we live in a fast town cruising around
eating hashbrowns going to chick-fil-a
or McDonald's Burger King what you say
jack-in-the-box
you go in Subway I don't think they have
those not today not tomorrow not the
week later no they don't serve taters